[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to zombie land back for seconds
after all this time well what can I say
but thank you get a lot of choices when
it comes to zombie entertainment and we
appreciate you picking us so you know
how Eskimos have a bunch of words for
snow a pooped Pixar puck Kaimuki sook
well the only reason we've survived the
last several years is that we've gotten
to know our bloodthirsty enemies better
than we know ourselves in the time since
we last saw you
zombies have evolved so we've given them
different names this lady here is
getting chased by the dumbest Z there is
what we call a homer in a world without
YouTube who isn't entertained by a homer
[Music]
unfortunately for every Homer there's a
Hawking as in Steven or maybe his
slightly less accomplished sister
Beatrix who still got some brains left
to figure [ __ ] out lever girl okay last
one what was that okay all right well
this time let's play name that zombie
the ninja silent deadly the first thing
you hear is your own screen you can
imagine how thrilled we were to crack
the zombie code but life is about more
than just survival ever since we were
evicted from our normal lives I'd been
searching for a place to put down roots
my old pal Tallahassee has the saying go
big or go home
it's not his signature phrase but it did
give me an idea why not go big and go
home
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hail to the mother [ __ ] chief there
are worse places to hang your hats
Casablanca wait why does he get to be
president well I think I would have made
a damn fine president just a few hand
chick a few babies you would have
brought a real dignity at the office
thank you you don't have what it takes
I'll be President uh-huh and I nominate
Little Rock it's my VP so that means I
get to be President if you get killed by
zombies that wasn't what I was thinking
when I offered you the position but
technically yes I have this rule enjoy
the little things which is what we spent
a lot of time doing in those early days
at the White House and it was a really
special time making a house our home
[Music]
Wichita I had fallen into our own
version of domestic bliss
well not quite bliss but domesticity to
be sure today explain fulfill off again
no it did not fall off I took it off
it's so creepy he just stares at us all
night that stare emancipated the slaves
okay and it ended the civil war we
should be grateful he's going out do you
remember what happened the last time you
took the blindfold off you made me sleep
on the lincoln couch you so much baby
you are so gorgeous
yeah we really need to find you someone
that's we're on any romance left in me
belongs to the Beast here hey well don't
we need to find someone for me shouldn't
be a problem long as you're open to
dating zombies seriously what I'm never
gonna find a boyfriend or get married
have a family where are you family so
when I have three in bed little rock had
a strong desire to leave the nest and
let's just say Tallahassee wasn't the
most understanding father figure bedrock
but for better or worse we were a family
and for the first time since the virus
we were living somewhere truly safe
making every day feel like well like
Christmas morning hello hey tell Santa
what would you like for Christmas little
girl a pony no I'd actually really like
you to stop calling me little girl well
technically you are little and you're a
girl well uh I am NOT a little girl
Santa but do you know what I would like
I don't even [ __ ] with you bite it's not
to sound too sentimental but those days
at 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue may have
been the best days of my life and that's
counting crazy
wait a second oh my god no it's a
first-edition Tolkien man and you wrote
in it there's my name right there luring
this perfectly preserved paper
thank you send yours too you didn't stop
thank you so much a bit touching
hey you know I couldn't find any
wrapping paper but don't worry about
just tear it open that matters only Taft
he's our fattest president so there's
actually quite a lot left over if you
need some wrapping paper why miss I
didn't get anything from you just what I
wanted another gun oh not just any gun a
colt 45 and not just any colt 45 the
King's England Denmark Liechtenstein
there's only one King Aaron [ __ ]
greatest who ever lived with King of
Kings he gave this gun to Nixon when he
visited the White House and I am I give
it to you locked and loaded
yeah he said shoot that colt in his
backyard king's palace Memphis Tennessee
yeah tell you about Graceland only like
a hundred times well we're gonna go
there together so no actually think I'm
gonna go shoot this right now I think I
saw some deeds down by the reflecting
pool I'll go with I'm gonna go by myself
it's Christmas it's not [ __ ]
Christmas
it's November 17 Little Rock was on the
hunt all right for people her own age
and the thing is they were out there we
just made it a point to keep our
distance which would kind of suck if you
were the one stuck in the nest
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
light them up
Oh
[Music]
very Christmas do you know what I would
like I don't know what did you like
[Music]